hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to make me a sandwich the
game where you too can experience all
the wonders and joys of making yourself
a sandwich as you can see before you is
spread out the buffet of ingredients for
your goddamn sandwich why the [ __ ] am i
playing this okay so I was gonna try to
like upsell this game literally you just
make a sandwich I don't have I can't
even move I don't know how to do this I
can't grab them why is it no door why am
I stuck in here this is my perpetual
hell just stuck in here making a
sandwich everyday for the rest of
eternity oh oh I've got some vibrations
in the tomaters so when I click and hold
on the tomatoes oh it's your dangly do
oh it's a dangly oh so I have to oh
that's adorable but how do I bring it
closer to me you don't you didn't
explain how to actually bring it closer
okay so I'm just gonna operate on the
subject this is not a sausage this is
not a sausage this is either a turd or a
disembodied penis and I don't know which
is worse at this time but I'm gonna put
it in my sandwich anyway nothing like a
dick turd sandwich to lighten my day
about a donut on that thing
okay well that didn't work how are you
they're all in the different distance
planes that's right you better stop
[ __ ] how am I supposed to be there was
no instructions in this game it's a
[ __ ] stupid game how the [ __ ] is
that supposed to tell me what it's
supposed to do good god I'm getting
infuriated I knew I was picking my
battles on this when I was like I play
this game it's gonna be stupid I know
that alright so put the egg in the
basket
oh well that works maybe I got a throath
oh oh this sandwich is coming together
that is not a piece of a sandwich
material
excuse me but that plate just flow down
low gravity wait a minute hang on a
second here somethin ain't right about
the physics in this environment see I
got a lot of questions see I look at a
game and I wonder what got me in this
horrible hellhole that I find myself in
and I've recently discovered that
gravity don't [ __ ] work so how in the
hell is this supposed to get together
into a sandwich because I can't even
make these things fall on the right way
what are you doing that's not a sandwich
get horizontal yup
dumb so we need some tomatoes on this
[ __ ] BAM this is a good-looking
sandwich right here oh that's not on the
[ __ ] sandwich you douche I said okay
now I figured out the secret you got an
angle the trajectory so it falls in a
precipitous manner to go on your goddamn
sandwich how about it do not oh oh that
wasn't even close and oh it's got the
curse of the verticals No don't you
knock any of the other ingredients off
this oh you sack of [ __ ] what happens if
I throw you down like that ooh
you didn't do it you filled like a
maroon no man this is gonna be harder
than I thought okay so we got all the
basic ingredients on my sandwich so I
just gotta cap this off and then wonder
why the hell I started this video yeah
no I forgot the dick turds what am I
supposed to can i thread this through
the donut can I get this [ __ ] I'm
[ __ ] on my sandwich as it was
suddenly very important to me that's not
on there
good no come on
Oh [ __ ] ah no there we go okay so if
I can just thread this donut with this
dick sausage dish what no no I won't
have a floating dick sausage dick turn
sausage floating in the air is word
draws a line I came here to make a
[ __ ] sandwich I have to deal with
this why I did why why why I need did
gravity suddenly turn off do these just
not fall anymore what's going on up
there whoa I found the vortex apparently
witness oh now they fall oh now they
fall okay well this is my only dick turd
sausage left so I better not do nothing
wrong with it oh god no okay so the
problem is now it's not horizontal come
on get horizontal you're just getting
closer to me and I don't like that
Oh Oh God let's go Oh God the shadow of
the dick it's right in front of my face
what the [ __ ] just down I move no I mu I
move my character just moved oh jeez hey
hey how's it going there have you seen
my sausage Jesus saw jeez I'm getting a
little excited about this sandwich so
that tells me I might have to actually
boil this out because that's a little
too phallic like anyway let me just
finish out the sandwich dad
no no doughnut okay that's good enough
okay so I am done making a sandwich I
hope you enjoyed this video because I'm
not sure if I'm going to post it but if
I do it's gonna go in the weird game
category that's for goddamn sure so
either way that was make make it meet
Lee
that was making me a [ __ ] sandwich
you can play this for yourself if you
want to I don't know I don't know why
you would you got all the sandwich
making capabilities out of this video
right here it was good enough for my
very good delicious sandwiches but
either way I'll put a link in the
description if you want to play it so
thanks for watching really hope you
enjoyed it
sorry I wasted your time have fun making
sandwiches out there thanks so much for
watching and as always I'll see you in
the next video bye
okay fine I'll post it